ted my friend yes bill my friend i
believe we are going to accomplish
the rare long delayed sequel that'll
actually be satisfying
most excellent
[Applause]
[Music]
bill and ted face the music
so um before anybody asks no i don't
currently have plans to review
new mutants or tenant because regardless
of whether or not they're playing close
to me
i do not feel comfortable and safe going
to movie theaters right now
whereas building tip was something i was
able to see at home not at the
most inexpensive cost so i'm not sure
it's necessarily economical to do that
unless you know you get a bunch of
people around and you know
three or more people it's worth the
price to get it on amazon which is how i
watched it
that's not a plug for amazon that's just
the truth of the logistics of things
so bill and ted is a franchise that
i grew up on to a certain degree i
didn't i wasn't like
really uh at the first wave of it i
think i had a babysitter once was like
you haven't seen bill and ted's
excellent adventure that was basically
my introduction to or at least my
introduction to the idea
to my memory i actually saw bogus
journey first
i my memory of that is a little bit
vague but that's that's
what i remember and it's i mean
they're fun movies i i went back and
rewatched excellent adventure with liz
for the first time for her because she
hadn't seen it in a while
and as far as that era of comedies go
it holds up better than most and
i think it helps that these guys are
just so
lovably endearing and that you know
they're not
smart but they're also they're not
jerks the way a lot of protagonists from
comedies of that point in time tended to
be especially now going back and
watching them going oh my god you're not
funny you're
just an ass so
that's it's nice to see something a
little bit more wholesome
occasional specific brief jokes
notwithstanding
so i haven't rewatched bogus journey in
a bit but
they're just they're fun they're
inventive
it's really easy to get attached to the
leads they're just the right mix of
goofy and well-meaning and a little bit
dim but
they just they just want they just want
the best they just want things to be
excellent for everybody and so
i always kind of found the idea of doing
a third one to be
a little bit dubious i it was one of
those things i was like
really did do we need that
does that have to be a thing that exists
and i'm not sure that this
final execution proves that it needed to
exist but it does prove that it can
exist and
not tame what came before and feel like
oh
yeah these were fun weren't they
so let's start with our leads bill s
preston esquire and ted theodore logan
so keanu has never really gone from
the public eye and he slips back into
ted
very easily but i think we all expected
that the much nicer thing
is seeing alex winter again as bill alex
winter has continued acting
but usually in one-off appearances on tv
enrolls in very small films
he has not been in the public eye for a
long time and seeing him play bill
made me realize oh i missed you
yeah he's just and i always i almost
kind of liked bill
a little bit more than ted anyway so
maybe that's part of it but
i was really just
pleased just how effortlessly he slipped
back into that because i never had any
doubts about counter not that i had
doubts about alex winter but i hadn't
seen him in anything for so dang long
it was just nice and the two of them
have not lost a step
in their chemistry they both know still
how to play these characters
uh it's not like when you know say
bruce willis is brought back to play
john mclean and you're like are you even
playing the same character or are you
just playing your current
stock character and claiming that it's
john mcclane
whereas these guys are like oh no i
don't know you still got it
now obviously we have had some losses we
no longer have george carlin to come in
as rufus there is a nice little
acknowledgement of him
which i certainly appreciated and
kristen shaw plays his daughter
i feel like she's slightly underused or
maybe not underused maybe misused she
only has a couple of moments where i'm
like yeah there you go
i she's a good pick and she doesn't
perform badly i just don't think the
script
knew what to do with her aside from well
she's rufus's daughter
that's enough right yeah i guess
speaking of offspring though
so bill and ted's kids
from the end of bogus journey little
bill and little ted
uh actually turn out to be daughters
so that's that's billy and theo
they're a lot of fun and they're and
they're both very clearly
channeling the persona of their parent
characters
it's really fun just watching
these very outdated and specific
personas
of bill and ted being inhabited by these
young these 20-something year old women
like that should be gimmicky that should
be cheap they should be like oh yeah
fine we get but no they they both do it
so well
and especially like working off each
other and working off their dads
it's great it's wonderful and actually a
lot of the returning
cast is is fun in that way death
somewhat similarly
um it's it's just fun to see him again
and as far as the premise goes so
we've always had the assumption that
bill and ted were going to
create music that was going to unite the
whole world together and make
the utopian future that we've seen
glimpses of well
something's going wrong and it's not
just the future that's at stake it is
all of reality that is coming apart
because these guys haven't made the
music
that unites the world yet and their ban
pretty much went down the plug hole
and they're still trying and nothing is
working at all and their marriages are
starting to fall apart
and that premise has the potential to
sour you know what came before like
oh i'm just gonna sit here and watch
characters that i
love be losers and fail and normally
that would turn me off except the thing
is bill and ted were always
kind of losers so first of all it fits
much better
and also because they haven't changed as
people
it's not like seeing oh my hero is now
just an absolute bottom of the barrel
why am i even watching this like no
they are the same as people they just
haven't accomplished what they thought
they were going to accomplish by this
point in their life
and where things go with that ultimately
by the end i also kind of liked it's not
it's not the most shocking thing in the
world i didn't call it as far in advance
as i think
i i might have expected to if i were
looking at it on paper
but i did figure out where it was going
and i like where it's going
it's it's nice and it's a it's a good
pleasant way to to sort of wrap
everything up in a nice neat little bow
that feels very
positive and affirming and i think
that's another thing
i miss positive movies
and television and maybe part of it is
like just the state of the world
that i'm just seeing things through a
more
cynical lens uh you know in my life
but i i forgot how nice it is just to
have something
pleasant not with this underlying
current of darkness but it's just
nice i've missed things that are just
nice
i don't want to oversell it it's not
amazing but it is in keeping with the
previous two films and i think
holds up relative to them i think if
there was
one element that i was a bit iffy on i
liked him initially but then the more
he was on screen the more i was like oh
and then and
there's this robot from the future
and i don't want to dive into him too
much because he's a bit of a later
um addition as far as the narrative goes
and i don't really want to get into
spoilers not that this is a movie that
is really dependent on big twists or
anything but i just like to be
respectful of that
but when he's first introduced there are
little
small elements and hints at personality
that i really liked
but then when they became more explicit
and he
and that personality became more front
center i'm like oh
you're actually kind of annoying i like
those as background features like
you were a robot with these hints of
personality but now
you're just uh you're just kind of an
annoying person
it's just how you come across at this
point he doesn't drag anything down but
i think they took
what was what was fun and pleasant just
kind of
ran it into the ground with that
character but he's not in a ton of the
film so it doesn't it doesn't
wreck things too much as far as some of
the things we see
with um there's there's time travel in
both directions there's time travel
going forward and i don't feel like this
is a spoiler spoiler because it was in
the trailers
with bill and ted trying to um
find a point in their own future when
they've written the song
so that they can then take it back to
the present and perform it
um and they're they're going through
these
increasingly further down the line time
jumps and
just not seeing good for their own
future
and the girls are going back through
time and gathering up musicians to play
in the band
and i really enjoyed um
who they picked for these um
part of me kinda wishes they brought
beethoven back
since there's precedent for him in the
series but
minus that i like the mix of musical
types of
points of history i that all worked out
really well
and it's ju it just comes together
nicely and pleasantly with a it has a
really good understanding of its own
history
as a franchise like this is just fun
much like the previous two films it's
not amazing it is not a war
it's not a life-changing film it's not
like life reaffirming or anything but
it's just nice
it's fun it's sweet it's got a good
closing message that i really really
like it ends
super abrupt though like it's not that
it's not like it doesn't have an ending
it does
it hits the point that it needs to but
pretty much as soon as it establishes
what it needed to establish for the
ending to work
it just stops there's no there's no wrap
up
after that it's just and there we go
boom done
um i guess bogus journey kind of ended
somewhat
similarly but i don't know that didn't
feel as abrupt to me anyways
minor nitpick this is fun it's it's not
amazing or incredible but if you like
these films i don't think you'll be let
down
by villains that face the music have you
seen it what do you think about it
whatever your thoughts are drop
something down the comments let's talk
about it i have a patreon which is how i
am able to do things
like afford to rent uh the thing over
amazon
and it helps keep this whole operation
going if you're able to help me out at
any level that is
greatly appreciated even if you're not
liking sharing subscribing
all of those sorts of things do help me
out as well
so i would encourage that but i also
can't really tell you what to do
because end of the day you are the
council i just run the meetings and
until next time this council
is adjourned
[Music]
[Music]
um
um
[Music]
so bill and ted
oh my god dog seriously
seriously stop it